j'aurais pu faire l'émission seul nom
mais alors je vous dis béatrice
quoi je vais pas commencer à
castaldi c'est son anniversaire excusé
sans rigoler s'il a dit un mot dans
l'émission c'est beaucoup la seule chose
qu'il a fait ces galops c'est sa femme
non mais sans déconner trophique mais
j'adore mais mais mais pour mais il s'en
est mathieu je sais pas si tu as regardé
l'émission je n'ai pas eu cette joyeuse
bonheur mais chacun sinon j'aurais été
là non mais je te le dis moi j'ai du mal
à vous croire ah non mais s'ils n'ont
même pas une habitude
est-ce qu'ils parlent d'habitude non
mylène présence karabakh et la gueule
public
présent c'est
quand c'est pas mon débris lors alice et
béatrice elles prennent leurs marques
merci leur a dit arrêtez avec la loi
dites ce que vous pensez ici il n'ya
qu'une noire c'est la mienne ok
ok donc arrêtée doit être arrêté avec la
loi art était ok béatrice on n'est pas
l'américaine ici on dit les choses les
américains ils sont hypocrites les
français non ok dit les choses quand
vous avez un truc à dire vous le dites
ah c'est pas la peine de faire comme ça
avec la tête et quand on arrivait ou non
me
nazer lui alors lui hier je n'ai même
pas qu'il était là mais ça arrive mais
non tu étais où messi non plus si c'est
même moi j'ai rigolé un peu fort à 20h48
également j'ai fait une intervention qui
a fait le buzz je dis oui en a marre des
polémiques soient payés rire vaut aussi
par son réseau les noms mais les mecs
c'est passe à la télé la télé c'est tous
les soirs sachez le c'est comme le
public quand il à nous voir c'est un
événement pour lui et bien pour nous
tous les soirs on doit faire les
missions comme si c'était la première
voyons pas donc c'est pas on va
s'endormir sur ces bruits parce que je
vais vous dire moi ya pas de lauriers
les lauriers ça dégage celui qui
s'endort il reste chez lui dort d'accord
ok moi se ressaisir et que les équipes
merci
mais qui découvrira d'inwi géraldine je
peux rien dire elle était un petit peu
en dessous hier moi mais j'avais pas
envie de l'entendre
mais géraldine et je le dis pour moi les
deux qui font la meilleure saison
vraiment de l'année je le dis j'ai pas
peur de rien c'est gilles et géraldine
donc j'ai rien à dire gilles et
géraldine ces voix là c'est mal c'est le
meilleur c'est non nous a été très bon
tous ouais mais ces jours meilleurs non
mais oui mais vous êtes très bon mais
vous êtes là une fois sur trois donc
c'est pas pareil à magasins constant
ceci pour être bon il faut être bon
quand on est à mathieu est toujours bon
quand il a envoyé tellement mais il faut
être là souvent alors il a qui sont là
souvent et j'adore quand ils sont là
benjamin voilà même s'ils n'étaient pas
là ce serait pas la même émission à
wissant rigoler c'est vrai parce que ils
parlent pas mais on sent on sent la
tension qu'il est là parce qu'ils pètent
donc on sent qu'ils veulent
et ça époux bernard montiel heures voilà
se dit c'est l'histoire de sa carrière
il a toujours été là et on n'a jamais su
pourquoi
vraiment c'est l'histoire de sa carrière
il a fait toute une carrière à chaque
fois qu'il ya dans une fois la moitié
des quelques mois ce qu'il fout là nue
et ben c'est pareil ici quand les gens
il vaut mieux qu'ici vous l'un voilà
c'est pareil mais on est content après
on s'habitue au diabète shine et là
c'est pas grave isabelle morini-bosc
débat franchement oui alors
rien est vraiment réagi rien à liège a
rien à dire
meyer vous n'étiez pas là et c'est un
drame filmé yeux non dites pas ça mais
je fonçais ce soit on va voir
qu'isabelle est en grande forme le sang
qui la belle va faire une super émission
ce soir
quand vous le sentez ronald l'enjeu et
ou en tout cas je suis positivement
ravis
[Rires]
et gilles verdez regarder il vient ici
balade juste pour libérer fatou puisque
fatoumata luzoir d'autres hommes et
heureux un idée là il est toujours là
chaque arrêt jeudi gilles sera pas
toutes les émissions mais est à chaque
fois il est là il est magnifique c'est
vrai c'est fou ouais c'est vrai pour
satoci ce soir là une soirée elle était
content que vous m'appeliez
c'est sympa